but how do you then take these and make
them sort of valuable language learning
opportunities hi there steve kaufman
here and today i want to talk on a
subject that i've talked about before
how to use netflix and youtube and other
video material
to learn
whatever language you're learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you use apple podcast or spotify
or
other podcast services
don't hesitate to leave a review okay
so
language learning as we know is about
motivation that's the driver that's the
spark plug that triggers your interest
your curiosity
and content which feeds that curiosity
feeds those interests is is extremely
important
content that you like content that is
has resonance for you and you know when
i
first started learning uh say chinese
and then french back 50
60 even years ago it was overwhelmingly
books and then
came along you know more and more tape
recordings and cassette recordings
and then i went through a period and you
can see behind me i have a shelf and
it's not the only one full of cds
uh
because there was a period where i was
buying audiobooks and cds to match you
know books and there's reading books in
behind me
and but now increasingly on the internet
we have all kinds of resources that we
can bring in
to our sort of language learning world
to learn from and videos are quite
powerful now i have in the past expect
expressed some reservation about videos
because of course the problem with the
video is you're pro you know you're
obliged to sit there and watch it and
there can be long periods of time in any
video any you know series on netflix or
movie or whatever
where there's not much dialogue so
you're just watching people move or cars
drive or people shoot or whatever they
do
and so it's less sort of language
intense word intense than say a book
or even an audio book
where you are relying on what you read
and what you hear to learn and i find
that is very powerful in terms of
learning because you're having to
conjure up meaning based on these words
that you hear so you're becoming more
and more used to these words
however
movies and series
are extremely attractive
and
because so much of language learning is
connected with our emotions
i have found that say
watching a series on netflix even when i
don't understand very well it could be a
series in turkish or a series in arabic
or
again a movie a youtube video in persian
the good thing about a series is that
you meet the same people
every time in every episode so it's as
if you're you're getting together with
your family your turkish family or
whatever language you're learning i
happen to have been into turkish persian
and arabic
so you're getting together with with
your friends and with your family and
you're seeing them in in different
situations and always in somewhat
familiar situations because typically
many of these series are very low budget
so that's all done in the one studio and
it's always the same place and it's very
comfortable and you know familiarity and
comfort also helps us in language
learning but how do you then take these
and make them sort of valuable language
learning opportunities
so
i'm going to leave in the description
box some of the things that i use
uh
first of all if i if it's a movie on on
youtube
we do have a
link we have a
browser extension that allows us to
import that as a lesson so immediately
you get the
um
the video
the audio
and the transcript in other words the
text if in fact a subtitle you know
subtitles exist for that video which
isn't always the case
and so there is another um little bit of
a program called zero to hero which
helps you find
uh it's all going to be in the
description box it helps you find videos
in the languages you're interested in
where in fact you know closed captions
exist because once the closed captions
exist you can then import this as a
lesson into link
now we are also able to capture
videos and
subtitled dialogues from netflix
but netflix doesn't allow us to capture
the audio and it's very useful to have
the audio because sometimes you want to
listen to the audio um
without watching the video
so
but but that doesn't happen with netflix
however you can read
the script the text
and
you know get used to some of the words
there is also a piece of software called
learning languages with netflix i'm
going from memory but it's going to be
in the description box where you can go
through the video in netflix
frame by frame
and see the subtitles and look up the
words and so that's another it's got
nothing to do with link but that's a
piece of software that you may find
useful if you are using netflix to learn
languages now let me just see what else
was there there is another thing called
down sub
which is which enables you to download
closed captions from youtube and from
netflix as i say language learning with
netflix extension is one you'll see
these in the description box
um
so
and there are probably others you should
look into this and again nowadays you
know it's almost not necessary for me to
give you the names of different types of
software you can just google learning
languages with youtube learning
languages with netflix learning language
languages with amazon
prime or whatever it might be
and you're going to find a lot of
bits of software that are going to help
you
the way i like to do it
so i like to go through so so if i take
let's say i have this persian
uh
series that my tutor recommended to me
and part of the problem is is finding
you know
a series i mean you can also find a film
but the advantage of a series is that
each episode is 30 minutes long it's a
nice amount to do
you have to be at a certain level like
you have to have graduated from the more
sort of beginner material but 30 minutes
is okay
i go through the the
dialogue and 30 minutes sort of a 30
minute episode is probably only
10 minutes worth of concentrated
dialogue or 15 minutes like it's not 30
minutes because there's periods when not
there is
no dialogue and so i can go through that
and learn the words
and then i like to go and watch the
video now i have as i've said before i
have a stepper at home so i can get on
my stepper i can put on my ipad and i
can watch the movie and now i've gone
through some of the words so the second
or third time i watch it i actually
understand more and more and as i go
through the you know episodes
um
i gradually understand more and more of
it one thing i've asked my person tutor
to do
which is another approach i asked her to
give me like a
three five minute summary of each
episode
so the episode is say it's 30 minutes of
video uh if i take the uh
the url from youtube and i put it on
this uh website again you can google for
it which converts uh urls from youtube
to mp3 files
then i can go to my happy scribe
automatic transcription service i can
get the
the
video the audio transcribed so i can
study that in link
but then i ask my tutor because there
are errors in the automatic
transcription
to get a bit of a an overview of each
episode my tutor gives me
a three minute four minute summary of
that episode so again if we are more
kind of familiar with the what's
happening if we understand more
then it's easier to understand so that's
kind of the approach that i'm taking so
i watch the video once or twice
while exercising on my stepper or
whatever
uh
i then work on the transcript from the
uh the soundtrack
to get some of the
words
then i read the summary
depending on when my tutor sends me the
summary i might start with a summary
and so i get a better sense of what's
happening so that's one example
i did this egyptian arabic
egyptian arabic is tougher because there
are no there's no no subtitles in
egyptian arabic no transcript so i asked
my egyptian tutor
to
actually transcribe a whole
you know 30 minute episode it ended up
being 10 minutes that he had transcribed
and then recorded
and so that's kind of a work in progress
we're looking at how we can do that to
make it
you know more effective
um what else the other thing is we are
looking at ways actually within link and
link 5.0 but we're still you know a
couple of months away where
it will suggest youtube videos in
different languages and you can
immediately click and import them for
your own use you can't share them and
they will then be you know lessons so
rather than having to go and look for
videos in youtube it'll actually suggest
some to you right in the sort of
content library and then you can you'll
have the option of then going
to youtube bringing those into study so
if we can deal with the issue of where
to find things of interest to different
learners or to ourselves
how to extract audio
and and text from these
uh
that kind of prepares us to enjoy them
more whether we're watching them on our
ipad or on our televisions so it's just
an example of how
content has evolved
from you know what used to be books only
and and open real uh tape recorders and
then uh cassette
uh
tapes
and then cds
and now we've got all kinds of content
on the internet
so you know there are more and more
opportunities for us to enjoy our
favorite content and stay motivated in
learning languages so there you have it
thanks for listening bye for